okay let's go to the five six one area
code caller from five six one go ahead
and I'm sure you know that Jordan
Peterson was on the Joe Rogan podcast
about a month ago
mhm did you the Heathman interesting
point I think about economic hierarchies
work and inevitably he claimed that
inevitably there's going to be those at
the bottom all right and part of what
fuels and left is their empathy for
those at the bottom but he also planned
that there's a certain subset of people
who just have envy for the rich do you
think that long as we need to do that
you're saying that there's a line
between having empathy for the poor and
having envy for the rich is that what
you're saying yes sir okay and then but
what's the question where is the line I
don't know how would you define it on do
you think there's not any truth but do
you see any people on the left using
that as their as their reason not
empathy I'm sure you can find people on
all sides of the political spectrum that
Envy the rich I think given the sort of
celebrity culture and you know
glorification of being rich there's all
sorts of people that Envy the rich but
I'm not sure that it necessarily relates
to whether somebody has a preference for
a particular policy that could be based
on empathy in either case like I guess I
just don't see how it's one it's like
somebody could Envy the rich but
regardless even if they sort of like
stopped envying the rich they would
still empathize with the poor right okay
thank you
you wanted to make sure okay all right I
don't know that I've to answer the
question but all right but let's it's a
weird day it must be a full moon out or
something today